In one way machine learning grew
out of artificial intelligence,
artificial intelligence was about
creating machines that were themselves,
as smart as humans.
And along the way the field diverged
into different schools of thought,
including cognitive system which is
focused on thinking like humans.
And machine learning,
which is focused on creating machines
that act autonomously in general.
Regardless of whether or
not they're thinking like humans do, so
to start our conversation
about machine learning,
let's talk a little bit about
artificial intelligence in general.
And where machine learning fits in, to
do this we're going to borrow from one
of the classes at Georgia Tech called
Knowledge-Based Artificial Intelligence.
It's taught by Ashok Goel and I, and
the video that you're about to see
are covered very early in the course.
If you're interested you can find a link
to the full course in the instructor's
notes below.